[Music]
we showed you tape last night that was
so awful that we hesitated before
putting it on it's terrifying a hidden
driver in los angeles last august a 16
year old stole a car stole a car and
intentionally ran over a woman who was
pushing her eight-month-old son in a
stroller
we'll show you again it's disturbing
before we put it on the screen though we
should tell you that the mother and
child
are
well but it's still awful to see and you
should also the la backed the la soros
back district attorney george gascon has
announced the guy who did this will
receive a sentence of only five months
in a quote diversionary program
now the mother who was injured in that
attack is of course outraged obviously
what does it say about the value of her
life she's requested referred to only by
her first name rachel
we're honored to have her join us now
rachel thanks so much
thanks for having me tucker so that tape
is is really we actually debated whether
to put it on it's that awful i can't
even imagine how you feel when you well
how do you feel when you see that
you know at this point i'm pretty numb
to it i watched it about
you know i'd say at least a thousand
times i've still shot at it
to to see you know did i do what i
thought i did
um did i do everything i could to
protect my child and thankfully i think
i did
but it's it's it was very tough to watch
at first made me very sick
but i'm okay now watching it it seems
very obvious and i'm just looking on the
screen right now
there's space for him to avoid you and
your son but he it looks like he did it
on purpose
there absolutely he did it on purpose
you know i made eye contact with him as
he was approaching us i screamed for him
to stop
um you know there there was plenty of
room two cars can fit it's a one-way
street so
it's meant for just one car but you know
there are cars that can park on the side
of the road and there's still plenty of
room for another car to pass
so anyone who would mow down a mother
and her baby in a stroller on purpose is
someone who should be locked far away
from the rest of us no
absolutely and i just learned from bill
um illusion on sunday that the kid had a
felony record already and was out on
probation when he hit me
so how do you i mean this is almost a
rhetorical question how do you feel
about what george gascon has done what
message does that send
it
i mean it sends a lot of messages it
sends messages to criminals that you
know it's okay to do bad things because
we're not going to punish you we're
going to punish the victims instead
you know i'm just beside myself with the
comments that he's come out with on
twitter
citing that you know california law says
that the punishment is fair when in fact
it's his policies that he put into place
that prevent us from getting appropriate
justice
yeah i mean he assigns no value to your
life or your son's life at all it feels
like no
no i mean
he he he can take the time to to tweet
about it and and make this a political
thing which it's not um i'd like to
admit i'm a democrat and i voted for
george gascon i was raised in a
republican family so i'm pretty centrist
but i lean left
and you know his
i voted for this guy because i believe
that you know our prisons do need some
some reform but but rewarding criminals
um violent criminals for for their
actions is very far from from any kind
of reformation that anybody would think
is appropriate
yeah i mean it's it's it's a failure i
mean you know it the most basic duty of
government to protect its citizens
particularly moms with babies and
strollers i mean that's especially the
courts that's you know the courts are
here to protect us and he's rewriting
the laws essentially in los angeles
you know so that people can get away
with with whatever they feel like
are you going to stay in the state do
you think
not long term no you know we have plans
to move in the short term like the very
short term we'll stay in the state for a
little while but our long-term goal is
to leave the state
ah and so the future of the state erodes
so sad and you are brave to come on
especially since as you admitted it's
not it's not a political thing yeah so
thank you
yeah every every person in los angeles
should be concerned you know our crime
rates are through the roof and and we
need all the support we can get from
from both sides of the aisle all the
voters it's very nonpartisan amen well
you've done a great service in telling
your story thank you for that thank you
for having me
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight